c'est une figure majeure de notre époque
qui est décédé probablement l'un des
visages les plus connus au monde on va
encore beaucoup entendre son nom dans
les prochaines semaines et plutôt que de
parler de la famille royale tous les
jours pendant des semaines dans notre
format d actu du jour ce qui nous
empêcherait forcément du coup de traiter
suffisamment d'autres sujets absolument
cruciaux dans l'actualité bien je me
suis dit qu'on pourrait revenir sur sa
vie et quelques anecdotes assez
particulière dans le cadre d'une vidéo
spéciale c'est donc la vidéo que vous
regardez actuellement alors
installez-vous confortablement n'hésitez
pas et évidemment à prendre un petit et
et on commence tout de suite
[Musique]
elizabeth ii son nom complet elisabeth
alexandra marie est née le 21 avril
1926 à londres c'est la fille du prince
albert le deuxième fils du roi et
d'elisabeth pause laguiole lorsqu'elle
n'est donc ce n'est pas son père mais
bien son grand père qui est le roi le
roi georges 5 et oui pour ceux qui se
demandent c'est bien ce roi georges 5
qui a donné son nom à l'avenue georges 5
ou encore à la station de métro qui est
présente sur les champs-elysées à paris
lorsqu'elle naît et que georges 5 et
donc roi à ce moment-là elisabeth et
troisième dans l'ordre de succession au
trône britannique troisième donc après
d'abord son oncle edouard de galles puis
son père le prince albert le roi georges
5 tombe malade en 1929 il meurt
finalement en 1936 dix ans après la
naissance d'elisabeth à la mort du roi
c'est donc le premier fils de georges 5
edward gal qui devient roi mais chose
extrêmement rare il va abandonner le
trône moins d'un an plus tard un abandon
pour épouser sa femme ce qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas faire autrement puisque sa
femme était divorcé et c'était interdit
par la tradition d'épouser ainsi une
femme divorcée conséquence après ce
règne rapide c'est donc le père
d'elizabeth albert qui devient roi il se
fait nommer georges 6 pour résumer donc
elisabeth qui au départ avait peu de
chances de se retrouver un jour au
pouvoir et bien se retrouve désormais
première dans l'ordre de succession au
trône bon je passe rapidement sur
l'enfance d'elisabeth on peut tout de
même noter une ou deux choses
anecdotiques vu que mon cas même forgé
le personnage d'elizabeth à 18 ans par
exemple son père lui offre son premier
chien ce chien c'est donc un core guy ça
deviendra la race de chien préféré
d'elisabeth au total dans sa vie elle a
possédé une trentaine de corps guy qui
vivaient à l'intérieur du palais de
buckingham et qui avaient leur propre
chambre l'accord green room et où il
rien que ça il avait des draps changés
quotidiennement ainsi que des menus
gastronomiques et oui clairement une vie
sûrement plus luxueuse que nous tous
réunis d'ailleurs il y avait deux à
l'essai trois chiens derrière elle au
moment de sa mort alors cependant pas de
panique selon le média britannique
viennent de bundles elle avait élaboré
tout un plan pour leurs jours futur est
a priori donc on devrait prendre grand
soin de petits sauts dans le temps à 21
ans le 20 novembre
1947 elisabeth épouse philip man battle
un lointain cousin prince de grèce et de
danemark avec qui elle aura plus tard
quatre enfants d'abord charles le fameux
donc devenu le roi charles iii anne and
the who et edge led et là on arrive à
une date et un événement majeur dans la
vie d'elizabeth c'est celle de la mort
de son père alors âgé de seulement 56
ans le 6 février
1953 à ce moment-là elizabeth est en
tournée à l'étranger dans les pays du
commonwealth avec philippe pour
remplacer justement son père qui est
atteint d'un cancer du poumon et c'est
donc en afrique au kenya plus
précisément que elisabeth apprend la
mort de son père et sa proclamation
comme rennes à seulement 25 ans en 1953
elle devient donc non seulement reine du
royaume uni donc de l'angleterre de
l'ecosse et de l'irlande du nord ou
encore du pays de galles mais aussi la
cheffe du royaume du commonwealth cette
organisation qui regroupe de nombreux
états issus de l'époque coloniale
britannique comme le canada ou encore
l'australie et plusieurs pays d'afrique
qui reconnaissent donc la reine comme
étant leur monarque même si elle exerce
donc aucun pouvoir en réalité dans ces
pays et au passage sur ce sujet il faut
savoir que la reine et plus globalement
à la famille royale ont été sujets à pas
mal de critiques concernant ce passé
colonial de l' empire britannique et les
agissements donc de cet empire
britannique dans le monde on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans d'autres
vidéos sur la chaîne alors après 14 mois
de préparatifs le couronnement
d'elizabeth a finalement lieu le 2 juin
ce qui est assez impressionnant avec cet
événement à l'époque c'est que c'est le
premier événement de ce type à être
retransmis en direct à la télévision à
l'époque entre le direct le différé et
la retransmission au cinéma oui oui et
bien
277 millions de personnes ont suivi son
couronnement à travers le monde on verra
donc si le couronnement de charles iii
dans quelques semaines obtient une telle
attention en 1977 l'année des 25 ans de
règne d'elizabeth 2 le groupe punk
britannique des sex pistols décide de
sortir son célèbre morceau gordes save
the queen c'est donc aussi le nom de
l'hymne national britannique sauf que ce
n'est pas du tout une chanson élogieuses
de la reine au contraire il chante
notamment que la reine n'est pas humaine
et qu'elle représente selon eux un
régime fasciste à l'époque vous en
doutez la chanson a fait énormément
réagir et polémiques et elles mêmes
retirées des radios et des chaînes de
télévision ce qui ne l'empêchent pas de
monter tout de même tout en haut du
classement des meilleures ventes alors
avant de continuer sur sa vie je voulais
faire un petit aparté sur les tenues
vestimentaires d'elisabeth 2 qui ont
contribué sa renommée il ya sa
popularité est d'ailleurs un système de
paris s'était même mis en place pour
miser sur la tenue qu'elle ait porté la
reine à chaque fois en effet certaines
de ses tenues pouvait être même perçus
comme des gestes politiques par exemple
en 2017 un an donc après le vote sur le
bric site pour la sortie du royaume uni
de l'union européenne et bien elizabeth
ii s'était rendu au parlement
britannique avec un chapeau bleu
recouvert d'une fleur au coeur jaune vie
certaines personnes y ont vu directement
le drapeau européen et se sont demandés
si la reine n'était pas anti briques
site et qu'elle le montrer avec ce geste
cela dit d'après une conseillère
d'elisabeth 2 ce n'était qu'une
coïncidence autrement dit peut-être
qu'il ne faut pas non plus tout
surinterpréter autre élément par contre
à ses parents son célèbre sac à main
avait aussi une fonction alors si une
information qui n'a jamais été
officiellement confirmée par la famille
royale mais c'est une information qui a
été relayée par de très nombreux médias
à travers le monde en fait elle aurait
utilisé son sac à main pour pouvoir
communiquer discrètement avec son équipe
lors de cérémonies officielles en fait
apparemment c'est elle changé son sac à
main demain donc typiquement qu'elle
avait dans sa main gauche et que d'un
coup il passait à sa main droite eh bien
c'était pour dire discrètement qu'elle
souhaitait être exfiltré est donc sortie
d'ici bon fin de parenthèse on est
désormais en 1992 une année compliquée
pour isabey 2 puisque trois de ses
enfants sont en instance de divorce la
même année c'est notamment le cas de son
fils aîné le prince charles donc qui vit
une histoire très compliquée avec la
princesse diana et ce alors que de
nombreux journaux et médias people
britannique à l'époque il vient révéler
que le prince charles trompait la
princesse diana un autre événement vient
aussi ternir cette année 1992 c'est un
incendie dans le château de windsor qui
est son château préférées mais qui est
donc partiellement détruit d'ailleurs
elizabeth 2 qualifie cette année d'annus
horribilis
hisse donc littéralement d'année
horrible dans un discours prononcé le 24
novembre
1992 quelques mois après le 40e
anniversaire de son règne on arrive
désormais en 1997 une autre année
dramatique pour la famille royale
britannique en effet le 31 août 1997 la
princesse diana tout juste divorcée donc
du prince charles est victime d'un
accident de la route mortel dans un
tunnel à paris et ce alors qu'elle est
poursuivie par des paparazzi elle meurt
donc très jeune à l'âge de 36 ans tout
le pays est alors dévasté puisque diana
était extrêmement populaire et la reine
décide à l'époque de rester enfermé dans
son château de balmoral en écosse elle
ne réagit pas publiquement ce qui choque
pas mal de monde à l'époque le premier
ministre britannique de l'époque tony
blair insiste alors pour que la reine
s'exprime et prennent la parole sur le
sujet elle finit donc par accepter de
rentrer à londres et elle s'adresse en
direct à la télévision aux britanniques
quelques jours plus tard elle organisera
même des funérailles princière pour son
ex belle fille à nouveau petit second
temps nous sommes vingt ans plus tard le
29 juillet 2012 c'est beaucoup plus
récent donc à l'occasion des jeux
olympiques de londres elizabeth ii
apparaît dans une vidéo au côté de james
bond oui oui james bond interpréter donc
par l'acteur daniel craig alors ça peut
paraître assez anecdotique dit comme ça
mais ce jour là la reine a vraiment
surpris tout le monde en se mettant en
scène comme ça et ce alors qu'elle avait
toujours du respecté jusqu'ici un
protocole très strict et rigide
finalement on a fini par apprendre
qu'elle avait accepté de faire ce film
puisque c'est une fan des films de james
bond elle les a tous vus et puis les
jeux olympiques étaient forcément un
événement immanquable surtout pour elle
est d'ailleurs à propos de protocoles
stricts et rigide faut savoir que les
personnes qui rencontrait la reine avait
interdiction de la toucher les personnes
qu'il a rencontrées est est seulement
autorisée lui serrer la main mais
uniquement d'ailleurs si elle tendait sa
main en première georges pompidou avait
notamment rompu ce protocole en lui
prenant le bras devant l'elysée à paris
en 1972 par la suite elisabeth ii
continue de faire quelques apparitions
mais je voulais quand même vous donner
quelques chiffres qui ont été marquants
pendant ces années 2010 le 9 septembre
2015 par exemple elizabeth 2 devient le
souverain ayant régné le plus longtemps
au royaume uni jusqu'à ce moment-là elle
dépasse la durée du règne de son arrière
arrière grand mère la reine victoria qui
a régné pendant 63 ans 7 mois et deux
jours entre 1837 et 1900 d'ailleurs
c'est cette même année en 2015 donc que
sa mort a été annoncée par erreur par
une journaliste de la bbc sur son compte
twitter le jour d'un exercice interne de
simulation du décès de la reine en gros
visiblement elle n'avait pas été mise au
courant de cet exercice est donc à la
vraiment cru que la reine était décédé
elle a donc tweeté l'information pour
après rassurez vous je suis allé chez
caisson linkedin tout à l'heure
apparemment elle travaille bien toujours
à la bbc mais par contre elle n'a plus
de comptes twitter bon elizabeth ii a
également battu un autre record le 13
octobre 2016 puisque ce jour là est bien
le roi de thaïlande rama 9 décède et la
reine elizabeth ii vient donc le
souverain encan en fonction avec le plus
long règne ensuite ça après ça et bien
les apparitions de la reine se font de
plus en plus rares notamment à cause de
son état de santé puisqu'elle a
désormais plus de 90 ans à cette époque
l'arrivée dans la famille royale de
meghan markle la femme donc du prince
harry ternie aussi un petit peu l'image
d'elisabeth 2 en effet meghan markle
raconte lors d'une interview en 2021
avec la présentatrice américaine oprah
winfrey qu'elle a été confrontée selon
elle à du racisme au sein de la famille
royale toujours sur ce sujet la même
année une enquête du média britannique
de gardienne pointe également du doigt
via des documents et bien les pratiques
ce cri minatoires de certaines
institutions de la famille royale sans
pour autant nommer directement la reine
on y apprend notamment que buckingham
par l'ess a interdit aux minorités
ethniques d'occuper des fonctions
officielles
jusqu'aux années 1960 le 9 avril 2021 on
en avait parlé d'ailleurs dans les
accuse jours son mari philippe meurt à
l'âge de 99 ans elizabeth 2 se trouve
donc veuve après 73 ans de mariage en
2022 à l'âge de 96 ans elle devint le
premier monarque de l'histoire du
royaume-uni a célébré son jubilé de
platine qui marque donc le 70e
anniversaire de son accession au trône
elle apparaît pour l'occasion au balcon
du palais de buckingham à londres elle
se place donc désormais à la seconde
place des monarques ayons eu le règne le
plus long juste derrière le roi français
louis xiv qui a régné pendant 72 ans
alors durant son règne et jusqu'à sa
mort cette semaine elizabeth 2 a
rencontré des centaines de dirigeants et
chefs d'état à travers le monde elle a
notamment vu défiler 9 prises dans
français pendant son règne d'ailleurs au
passage petite anecdote élise avait deux
parlait couramment le français elle a
notamment prononcé un discours en
français devant les sénateurs lors de sa
visite à paris en 2004 cet anniversaire
donne un sens particulier à marie 10 14
la ktm que j'ai effectué en france son
mari philippe parle est également
français couramment il avait donné
plusieurs interviews à des médias
français avec un français quasiment
parfait élise avait 2 laisse donc
derrière elle une nation endeuillée
nombreux défis par ailleurs attendent
son fils le roi charles iii un roi qui
n'est pas aussi populaire aujourd'hui
que sa mère je vous invite d'ailleurs à
aller voir notre vidéo des actus jours
sur le sujet dans tous les cas ça me
semblait donc intéressant aujourd'hui de
me plonger dans la vie de la reine
elizabeth 2 j'espère en tout cas que
cette vidéo vous aura plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les
commentaires et puis à vous abonner pour
ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes je
tiens d'ailleurs vous annoncer qu'on
reprend le tournage de reportages je
pars notamment en reportage deux fois
dans les deux prochains mois donc ça va
être assez chargé et ce sera disponible
directement sur cette chaîne youtube
j'ai très hâte de vous dévoiler tout ça
je vais vous voulez découvrir d'autres
vidéos sur d'autres thématiques que ce
soit mon interview de max verstappen
françois hollande thomas pesquet ou
alors plein d'autres personnalités
rendez vous directement donc sur cette
chaîne youtube connaissances vous prions
de reproches et on se dit du coup a très
vite